[Musik]
heute wurden harte Maßnahmen zum
energiesparm beschlossen Schaufenster
müssen in bestimmten Zeitfenstern dunkel
bleiben Leuchtreklame wird ebenso
untersagt und es kommen Einschränkungen
auf uns private Bürger zu und damit
herzlich Willkommen zu viertel nach acht
meine Gäste heute Abend sind der grüne
Bundestagsabgeordneter Janecek er sitzt
seit 2013 im Bundestag und ist auch
Politologe seine Forderung rettet die
Kulturstätten bildpolitikchef und
Volkswirt Jan Schäfer sorgt sich nicht
nur um die Wirtschaft ihn beschäftigt
vor allem auch die Übergriffigkeit des
Staates annabelle krughoff ist
Friseurmeisterin und überzeugt Handwerk
statt Studium wir brauchen wieder mehr
Wertschätzung für das Handwerk last but
not least dr dr Reinhard zittelmann erst
Historiker Soziologe und Bestsellerautor
heute bricht er eine Lanze für die
Sparer ja und eine etwas unpopuläre
these auch die Reichen sein von der
Inflation betroffen mal sehen ob ihm das
philop einbringt mein Name ist Nena
schick und mein Thema heute Abend ist
frieren ist nicht solidarisch machen wir
mal einen Gedanken stellen Sie sich vor
Sie gehen ins Büro mit Mütze Handschuhen
und Daunenjacke bepackt und sitzen dann
dort den ganzen Tag bewand sie können
sich gedanklich ehrlich gesagt schon
darauf einstellen denn in diesem Winter
könnte soweit sein öffentliche Gebäude
dürfen ab Ende kommen der Woche in der
Regel nur noch bis maximal 19 Grad
beheizt werden bisher lag die empfohlene
Mindesttemperatur für Büros bei 20 Grad
Durchgangsbereiche wie Flure Foyers oder
Technikräume sollen möglichst gar nicht
mehr geheizt werden und auch für private
Unternehmen gibt es Regelungen die
Bundesregierung hat die
Temperaturgrenzen der
Arbeitsstättenrichtlinie geändert um
schnell kommen Heizsaison signifikant
Gas zu sparen auch die Regelung in
Mietverträgen über eine
Mindesttemperatur werden vorübergehend
ausgesetzt was kommt da auf uns zu wenn
man erstmal 19 Grad hört denkt man sich
naja worüber regt man sich denn
überhaupt auf aber was passiert denn
eigentlich bei weniger als 20 Grad
Raumtemperatur mit uns viele Menschen
fangen an zu frieren bei 18 Grad besteht
sogar die Gefahr sich zu erkälten auch
kann sich Schimmel in den Räumen bilden
frieren zufrieden ist das Motto dieser
Tage doch ich finde das ist alles andere
als solidarisch vor allem mit Blick auf
den Energieverbrauch der Wirtschaft ist
die angestrebte Energieersparnis nicht
mehr als fehlleitende Symbolpolitik auch
Arbeitnehmerverbände wie die IG Metall
schlagen bereits Alarm und sprechen von
einer Gesundheitsgefährdung Herr Janecek
können Sie die Verbände verstehen die
sich jetzt schon vehement dagegen
aussprechen kann sie ehrlich gesagt
nicht so richtig verstehen ich glaube 19
Grad jetzt in der Arbeitsstätte
beispielsweise ist zwar kraftbar man
muss ja jetzt auch nicht mehr im T-Shirt
rumsitzen den ganzen Winter und wir
müssen nun mal ein Stück weit runter
kommen von den hohen Verbräuchen 20
Prozent müssen wir als
gesamtvolkswirtschaft einspannen Energie
um sicher durch den Winter zu kommen
Gasspeicher werden gerade voll gemacht
auf der anderen Seite braucht es auch
Leistungen mir ist schon klar dass
natürlich jetzt der einfache Bürger das
nicht in erster Linie schultern kann
aber natürlich Büros Wirtschaft
entsprechend die sollen das machen und
die ein oder andere Maßnahme die nicht
bequem erscheint die muss halt auch
kommen weil wir müssen dieses Ziel
erreichen 20 Prozent wir haben eine
Krise viel Energieersparnis bringt es
uns wenn wir jetzt auf diese 19 Grad
gehen wo die Arbeitnehmerverbände ja
schon sagen dass man friert also und die
warnen jetzt auch schon vor hohen
krankheitsständen wie die IG Metall zum
Beispiel gewandt wird ja auch immer viel
das können wir aus corona-zeiten und
insofern würde ich sagen 19 Grad ist
verkraftbar und es gibt ja auch noch die
Möglichkeit eben nicht ein T-Shirt
anzuziehen sondern ein Pullover wenn man
arbeitet wenn man meint dass man friert
jetzt bin ich mal hart ja in der Antwort
und würde es mir selber auch zutrauen ja
insofern würde ich sagen 2 Grad
Einsparungen sind halt nun mal dann 10%
Gasmenge also und das ist wissen wir und
da wir das wissen und nicht im Februar
dastehen wollen dann alles abschalten
das möchte ich die Alternative glaube
ich brauche mal die Maßnahmen wenn es
gut läuft wir kommen mit dem LNG im
Winter dann früher rein dann kann man
auch wieder drüber nachdenken Maßnahmen
zu lockern aber wir haben auch ein
riesen Preis momentan den Leute zahlen
müssen das heißt Energie einsparen heißt
ja auch Geld sparen auch für den
privaten übrigens die Sprachen gerade
Alternativen an Herr janitschek das ist
ein wichtiges Wort und mich wundert dass
es bei der ganzen Debatte in das Thema
eigentlich eine Alternative gibt die
ihre Partei überhaupt nicht zur Kenntnis
nimmt und eigentlich permanent vor sich
hertreibt und sagt es gibt ein
gesellschaftlichen Konsens und deswegen
nutzen wir diese Alternative nicht da
geht es um das Thema Kernkraft und
letzten drei Meiler die sicherlich das
Problem am Ende nicht komplett lösen
aber die sicherlich dazu beitragen
könnten dass das was sie auch gerade
beschrieben haben und Nina Schink
natürlich nicht ganz so dramatisch
ausfällt wie es dann möglicherweise
ausfällt dann wenn wir diese drei Meiler
die wir haben zum Ende des Jahres
abschalten dann brauchen wir mehr Gas
für die Verstromung also die
Stromproduktion mehr dreckige Kohle und
deswegen noch einmal die Frage auch an
sie er könnte das mit ihrem Gewissen
eigentlich vereinbaren den Menschen zu
sagen wir gehen hier runter auf 19 Grad
in einigen sogar wenn es schwere
Tätigkeiten sind einigen Betriebsstätten
auf 12 Grad und gleichzeitig nehmen wir
drei funktionierende sehr sichere wie
der Typ sagt Kern Netzwerke einfach vom
Netz also was Bayern angeht wo ich
herkomme München haben wir ja nicht nur
eine gaslücke sondern möglicherweise
durchaus auch eine Stromlücke und
deswegen ist dort die Diskussion
aufgrund der sonderbeschaffenheit auch
durch die Staatsregierung verursacht
über Jahrzehnte so dass das sehr
ernsthaft zu prüfen ist ob ihr seit zwei
nicht verlängert werden muss das wird
gerade geprüft das wird Zeiten an
Ergebnis geben sie wünschen sich dass es
verlängert wird ich bin da im Einklang
auch mit übrigens meiner grünen
Stadtratsfraktion in München die sagt
wir müssen das sehr ernsthaft prüfen
weil das uns Szenario sein kann dass wir
da in Knappheiten prüfen ist was anderes
verlängern ist die Frage ja die Frage
ist ob sein muss und das wird er jetzt
gerade geprüft und das wird ein Ergebnis
geben
was die Frage sein muss also die
dreckige Kohle die muss sein und die CO2
nahezu CO2-freie Kernkraft da ist man
sich nach sechs Wochen Stress ist immer
noch nicht sicher ob das sein muss und
das verstehe ich nicht wenn man
gleichzeitig sagt Liebe Bürger Nina
Schink hat das ja sehr zugespitzt auch
Form ihr müsst frieren aber der
Kernkraft bei für die es übrigens 70%
für ein paar der Bürger für einen
längeren für längere Laufzeiten sind
übrigens auch die Mehrheit der
Grünwähler 54 Prozent sind auch dafür
Kernkraftwerke länger laufen zu lassen
da sagen sie ja das müssen wir also noch
prüfen warum kein klares Ja weil die
Entscheidung schon zu treffen ist ob wir
auch die Sicherheitsrisiken die sehr
wohl gibt in Kauf nehmen wollen weil wir
durchaus auch ein gesellschaftlichen
Konsens hatten und jetzt noch einen
Punkt der sie sagen natürlich würde
jetzt der Bürger dann mit 20 Grad heizen
können statt mit 19 übrigens kann er in
der Wohnung auch 22 machen wenn er will
aber zahlen wird das nicht wollen also
der Punkt ist am Ende da ist die
Kernkraft etwas was vielleicht zwei
Prozent von den 20% liefern könnte und
das war es dann schon also die Summe die
erbracht werden kann in der Kalkulation
der Risiken ist so gering dass man das
schon ganz genau angucken muss und wie
gesagt Bayern muss man ganz genau
angucken da ist eine Problemlage
woanders ist die Problemlage also nicht
da wir bleiben noch einmal bei dem bei
dem Grundthema frieren für den Frieden
ja also sie sind ja der Überzeugung die
Frau Schinken soll sich den Pullover und
die Daunenjacke bald mit ins Büro nehmen
am besten noch die Mütze aufsetzen wie
sehen Sie das denn wenn ich jetzt in den
Friseursalon gehe und meine Haare
gewaschen Kriege und die dann nur noch
kalt gewaschen bekommen muss ich muss
ehrlich sagen ich möchte diese
Einschränkung nicht haben ja also ist
natürlich schon so dass sich das nicht
vermeiden lässt im Friseurhandwerk auf
Strom oder Wärme zu verzichten es ist
natürlich auch wenn ich die Haare föhne
und das ist schon auf jeden Fall ein
Punkt der wird auch wahrscheinlich viele
andere Handwerksberufe betreffen
also ich kann das verstehen ich kann
irgendwie beide Seiten ein bisschen
verstehen und auf der einen Seite möchte
ich natürlich als Kundin nicht frieren
nämlich mich auch nicht erkälten auf der
anderen Seite bin ich auch verpflichtet
dem nachzukommen dass ich da glauben Sie
dass die Leute da noch kommen also wenn
ich mir jetzt vorstelle dass ich die
Haare in der kalt gewaschen Kriege und
der Friseur soll auch kalt ist muss ich
ehrlich sagen dann weiß ich nicht dann
besorge ich mir was aber macht sie bei
mir zu Hause selber also ist das nicht
auch ein Problem das vielleicht ein
Kunden sagen brauche ich gar nicht mehr
das hoffe ich nicht dass das passiert
weil ja das Handwerk ja auch eine
Relevanz hat entweder andere Hinsicht
aber ich würde schon sagen also zum
Thema Strom das wird langfristig für die
Handwerksbetriebe auch in finanzielles
Thema sein und ich hoffe natürlich nicht
dass die Kunden sagen dass wir den zu
kalt aber ich denke es wird eher in
anderen Stellen Problematiken geben was
dann die Unternehmer spüren werden Herr
Dr zittermann sie wissen ich betone
immer sie werden ihre beiden Doktor sie
sind der einzige Gast der zwei hat der
jemals war aber wie sehen Sie das denn
Freund also nicht Freunde aber ist für
sie frierend für den friedensolidarisch
und wie sehen Sie die heutigen
beschlossenen Maßnahmen also mir kommt
da immer erst was anderes in den Kopf
und zwar
viel haben wir gesagt wir würden die
Frau Merkel vermissen ja und ich
verfluche jetzt ehrlich gesagt jeden Tag
mal ganz hart gesagt weil sie hat die
Atom Netzwerke eher abgestellt klar
ursprünglich war es meine Entscheidung
von SPD und grün die hat uns abhängig
gemacht vom russischen Gas letztlich
dann die Kohlekraftwerke abgestellt
Fracking gibt es nicht ja und das sind
jetzt alles die Folgen die wir ausbaden
müssen ich finde es auch nicht richtig
wenn man sagt jetzt frieren für den
Frieden das so ist es ja nicht ja wenn
wir diese ganzen Maßnahmen nicht gehabt
hätten also die Atomkraftwerke würden
noch laufen jetzt nicht nur ein bisschen
länger sondern generell hätte man die
nicht abgeschaltet ja man hätte auch mit
den Kohlekraftwerken erstmal ein Stück
gewartet ja man hätte uns nicht so
abhängig gemacht vom vom russischen Gas
ja man hätte Fracking zugelassen da
hätten wir keines dieser Probleme jetzt
und das ist ja erstmal was mir so
politisch durch den Kopf geht ja ganz
persönlich muss sagen bei mir in der
Wohnung ist es immer unglaublich warm ja
die meisten Leute beschweren sich wenn
sie kommen und sagen das ist bei dir
viel zu warm aber ich habe auch noch
eine Klimaanlage die man auch zur Not
auf Wärme stellen kann dann zusätzlich
wird alle Stricke reisen habe ich sogar
noch eine Holz soll sondern von
Kohleofen den ich noch nie benutzt habe
also ich frage mich eigentlich auch wo
sie gerade sagen Herr titelmann sind
eigentlich viele Länder um Deutschland
herum bekloppt dass die jetzt auch die
Kernkraft ausbauen also mit welcher
Hybris gehen die deutschen grünen
eigentlich ran und sagen wir müssen erst
noch mal prüfen ob das überhaupt geht
wenn um uns herum ganz ganz viel Länder
sagen wir bauen sogar neue Kraftwerke
wir verlängern Laufzeiten wie Belgien
Kanada bezieht ein Großteil seines
Stroms aus der Kernkraft sind die alle
Gaga oder oder was ist da los also jetzt
mal ihre Meinung es wird seit 1999 wird
dieser große deutsche Weg gepredigt wir
sind Vorreiter bei der Energiewende wenn
ich mich auf der Welt umschaue 23 Jahre
später
sich eigentlich kein einziges Land
ehrlich gesagt was aus der
kernkraftausstieg aus der Kohle und 80
Prozent seines Stroms mit Energien aus
Erneuerbaren also Wind und Sonne
hinbekommen möchte und das jetzt schon
seit 23 Jahren das heißt schlafen die
alle sind die alle bescheuert sind nur
die Grünen in Deutschland schlau oder
oder sind möglicherweise die Grünen in
Deutschland gar nicht so schlau sondern
verpenn da was ich sage schon mal was
drauf geben bevor sie dann antworten ja
also es ist doch auch so man hat immer
so von grüner Seite gesagt nicht nur vor
den Grünen wir müssen jetzt so
vorbildlich sein und das so toll machen
unsere Energiewende dass dann die ganze
Welt sich das abguckt ja also wir waren
so ein bisschen die oberlehrmeister der
Welt am deutschen Wesen soll die Welt
gelesen hat mir früher auch schon mal
jetzt laufen die aber statt als
oberprediger als oberbettler laufen die
gleichen Leute durch die Welt von einem
Land zum anderen wir müssen ja heute
nicht über sie reden sondern wir können
gar nicht mehr reden und deswegen
natürlich die Frage
überspitz formuliert ja sind Sie denn
bekloppt geworden dabei also die
Energiekrise die wir heute haben die
haben wir ja nicht deswegen weil wir
keine Atomkraftwerke haben sondern weil
wir abhängig sind vom russischen Gas und
auch erdölexporten und wir zahlen jetzt
als Staat sie als Bürgerinnen und Bürger
darf man immer sagen 34 Milliarden Euro
für die gastumlage bis 2024 also das ist
das Geld was wir erstmal zusätzlich
aufbringen müssen zu dem paar Milliarden
die schon gezahlt wurden das sind
gigantische Beträge zu Atomkraft in der
Europäischen Union gibt es die Hälfte
der Staaten die hat die die andere hat
sie nicht die Franzosen haben ganz viele
müssen ganz viele gerade abschalten weil
nämlich wir Dürre haben Wasser ist nicht
mehr in den Flüssen da vergessen werden
wir müssen den auch Strom exportieren
also man kann sich dafür entscheiden die
zu haben ich würde das auch respektieren
das wird auch in der Welt so bleiben wir
als Bundesrepublik Deutschland haben uns
im Parlament mit über 90 Prozent der
Stimmen damals entschieden auszusteigen
das ist der Beschluss der auch von
keiner Partei in Frage
zugrunde gehen also es wird dann sagen
die moralischen wir sind musikalische
Bevölkerung aber am Ende kriegen wir es
nicht mehr hin also ich habe das ja
immer für mich hauptsächlich ökonomisch
argumentiert weil ich der Überzeugung
bin dass die Atomkraft sehr teuer ist
auch die Endlagerfrage ist ja teuer und
ich erneuerbaren Energien ja jetzt in
der stromgestehung in der Produktion
deswegen machen wir auch grünen
Wasserstoff jetzt mit Kanada so günstig
sind dass es überhaupt keinen Sinn mehr
macht neue Kraftwerk zu bauen also
Diskussion ist für mich rum es geht
allerdings noch darum zurechtfragen Sie
dass das noch mal mit den drei die noch
da sind da geht es dann aber auch nur
noch darum machen wir es noch ein paar
Monate und ich mache mal so ein paar
Jahre weil für die Gaskrise hilft uns
die Atomkraft nichts dafür müssen wir
Erneuerbaren ausbauen effizienter werden
und leider auch ein Stück weit noch mal
anderes Gas Einkaufen
lassen
alle die Belgier die jetzt verlängern
die Franzosen die sogar neu bauen die
Briten die Kanadier die die auf
Kernkraft setzen das kann doch nicht
also eine Partei die das für sich in
Anspruch nimmt so wie sie sagen und sagt
2011 haben wir das mit 90% mehr dem
Bundestag beschlossen die Motivation wie
sie gerade selbst geschildert haben ist
doch heute eine völlig andere und da
frage ich mich wo ist eigentlich die
Lernfähigkeit der Grünen da sind
offenbart große Teile der Bevölkerung
die 2011 auch für den kompletten
Atomausstieg waren doch viel weiter
haben sich doch geändert Herr sagen doch
wir sehen das anders und ich sehe auch
das überhaupt nicht dass sie sagen wir
lassen das nur ein paar Monate
weiterlaufen wenn der deutsche TÜV der
TÜV SÜD sagt es gibt kaum sicherer
Kernkraftwerke auf der Welt als die
deutschen Kernkraftwerke wir haben auch
noch drei abgeschaltet der zum
Jahreswechsel warum berauben wir uns
eigentlich freiwillig dieser
Energiequelle denn eins ist auch klar
das was Robert Habeck und ihre Partei
plant in der Ampel die der die
erneuerbaren Energien und die die die
Kapazitäten bis 2030 ja von heute zu
verdoppeln also innerhalb von acht
Jahren ob das klappt oder nicht das
steht in den Sternen das weiß niemand
und nur mal für den Fall das klappt
nicht was machen wir eigentlich dann
also wir sind ja völlig klar dass wir
für Versorgungssicherheit sorgen und
dass wir dafür sorgen dass der Ausbau
der erneuerbaren Energien drastisch
stattfindet der ist ja heute schon bei
fast 50 Prozent deswegen ist die
Situation ja auch nicht mehr mit 2011
wir haben ja jetzt ein sehr hohen Anteil
erneuerbarer im Netz und den können wir
gut gebrauchen zurzeit und wann sie
sagen immer die ganze Welt macht die
ganze Welt macht es eben nicht manche
machens manche machen es nicht
Situationen weil wir haben ja auch noch
vier weitere spannende Thesen den werden
Sie also sie werden aber noch mal zurück
finden
zum Thema zurück aber jetzt erstmal mit
der These von Dr dr Reinhard zittelmann
denn wir werden alle ärmer und ja alle
werden es
ja also ich habe mich ein bisschen
drüber geärgert dass jetzt oft so gesagt
wird Inflation die Reichen spüren es ja
gar nicht das Spüren nur die Arm ja auf
der einen Seite ist es schon richtig
also als jemand der jetzt selbst viel
Geld hat spüre ich natürlich nicht so
wenn die Lebensmittelpreise steigen oder
auch die Heizkosten das ist richtig aber
vergesst die Sparer nicht ja es gibt in
Deutschland ich glaube 60 Millionen oder
noch mehr Verträge für
Lebensversicherung ja die Leute die das
jetzt ausgezahlt bekommen ja dann andere
zum Beispiel ich habe ein Teil von
meinem Geld ich habe natürlich viele
Aktien und Immobilien da ist man nicht
so betroffen aber in Anleihen zum
Beispiel ja da gibt es heute ein Prozent
vielleicht und wenn ich dagegen neun
Prozent Inflation habe ja dann kann ich
mir ausrechnen was es dann bedeutet das
heißt der Sparer der wird im Moment
einfach vergessen und Sparer sie
natürlich jetzt die Armen in dem Sinn
weniger einfach weil sie nicht so viel
haben was ich sparen können deswegen
sage ich ja die armen sind betroffen
natürlich sehr stark von den Heizkosten
von was weiß ich ja aber alles in
Betroffenen besonders die Sparer sind
betroffen weil es ist ja eine Enteignung
was da stattfindet auf dem Weg und das
ist mein Thema heute
ja da ist natürlich die erste Frage
haben Sie eigentlich einen Pool die auch
Wohlhaben nein also da haben Sie schon
mal kein Problem mit den Sparmaßnahmen
dem Energiesparen der Regierung weil das
ist ja jetzt auch nicht mehr möglich
seinen eigenen Pool soll ja nicht mehr
möglich sein so als Baden ist möglich
aber was würden Sie vorschlagen also ihr
Lösungsvorschlag an die Regierung
leider muss man sagen dass es manche
Probleme gibt für dieses keine richtige
Lösung gibt ja das wird das Sagen
Kollege natürlich nicht gern und es ist
auch kein großer Trost für die Bürger
aber ein Hauptpunkt von der Inflation
ist sehr angerichtet durch die
Zentralbanken ja durch die
Niedrigzinspolitik was sie die ganzen
Jahre gemacht haben und klar das ist
jetzt als Politiker nicht eine Haltung
die man haben kann wir können ja nichts
dran machen aber ist auch ein bisschen
unehrlich den Leuten zu sagen wir können
die ganzen Freunde Inflation mit immer
mehr Staatsgeld sozusagen dann
beseitigen das wird am Ende nicht
möglich sein so ja das würde ich sogar
teilen also wir können nicht die Summen
die wir jetzt draufzahlen komplett
ausgleichen wir konzentrieren uns darauf
dass diejenigen die am wenigsten haben
wenigstens den Ausgleich kriegen weil
für die geht sonst eingemachte aber
meine Zahl zu nennen wir haben letztes
Jahr um die 70 Milliarden Euro
ausgegeben für fossile Energieimporte
dieses Jahr werden es 150 Milliarden
sein das sind 80 Milliarden mehr sind
zwei Prozent des Bruttoinlandsprodukts
das ist einfach Wohlstandsverlust und
der geht nächstes Jahr weiter aber
verspielen wir dann eigentlich unseren
Status als starke Mittel wir brauchen ja
den mit die Mittelschicht ist ja
eigentlich das was wir brauchen eine
starke Mittelschicht wie stark
verspielen wir das die Gefahr ist schon
da dass wir hier substanziell verlieren
in den nächsten Jahren nicht nur in
diesem einen Winter deswegen sind
Maßnahmen auf der einen Seite der
Entlastung notwendig aber auf der
anderen Seite eben auch Innovation
Kreativität Handwerk kommen wir später
noch hinzu also das war auch anpacken
also es wird auch eine kraftaktleistung
notwendig sein das einzig gute daran
eine Situation ist wenn man in der Krise
ist muss man schnell handeln muss man
kreativ sein dann werden wir auch
gezwungen sein schneller manche Prozesse
zu beschleunigen hoffentlich auch
Digitalisierung übrigens da sind wir
nämlich auch nicht besonders gut in
Deutschland Frau Gruber wie sieht es bei
Ihnen aus man sagt ja jetzt schon laut
Studien der 60% nicht mehr in der Lage
sind Rücklagen zu bilden wie sie es bei
Ihnen aus können Sie etwas zurücklegen
aktuell noch also es ist natürlich so
dass die corona-krise viele Bereiche
getroffen hat aber ich kann sagen durch
mein Handwerk dass das Handwerk ziemlich
krisensicher ist
klar sind unsichere Zeiten im Moment
aber ich würde trotzdem sagen
beim Handwerk das wird immer gebraucht
und das wird eigentlich täglich in
Anspruch genommen würde ich behaupten
dass es schon ziemlich krisensicher und
ich würde mich auch immer für den
Handwerk entscheiden weil sie haben
aktuell noch keine Not und sagen man
kann noch genug sparen in Deutschland
also man kann immer was zur Seite legen
weil man natürlich auch nie weiß was die
Zukunft bringt das ist klar aber ich
würde trotzdem
behaupten dass ein Handwerksberuf einem
schon gewisse Sicherheit gibt
noch ganz spannend ist was ich ganz
spannend fand und mir auch
aufgeschrieben habe untere Einkommen
Hartz IV Empfänger müssen keine
Gasanlage Zahlen Rentner und
Geringverdiener aber schon ist das
eigentlich fair die Frage wie
Rentnerinnen und Rentner jetzt auch noch
mal im Entlastungspaket drei oder
vielleicht auch hier wenn das noch kommt
auch entlastet werden müssen stellt sich
in der Tat weil die sind in den ersten
Paketen nicht dran gewesen das war so
das muss man auch
zugeben auf der anderen Seite gab es
eine rentnerhöhung im Summe von 6
Prozent die haben jetzt erstmal auch die
Arbeitnehmerin nicht gekriegt in dem
Fall aber sie haben eine Frage wo sie
den Punkt treffen den wir beantworten
müssen ja ich möchte noch mal auf das
Thema Altersvorsorge kommen ja weil wir
haben jahrelang auch die Politik gesagt
du musst auch privat für das Alter
vorsorgen die meisten Menschen wissen es
auch die haben dann angespart in
irgendeiner Form ich gebe zu die
Deutschen nicht so besonders clever
meistens ja aber drei Viertel von dem
Geld das liegt auf
Tagesgeldkonten Sparbüchern im
Lebensversicherungen und die sind alle
nicht inflationsgeschützt und das wird
ich glaube da haben sich viele noch gar
keinen Gedanken darüber gemacht aber die
Aktien sind ja zum Beispiel auch zum
Beispiel jetzt gerade im freien Fall und
auch nicht inflationssicher Aktien sind
schon wenn man längere Zeitraum anguckt
eher ein Inflationsschutz genau wie
Immobilien aber das haben wir die
meisten Deutschen nicht die meisten
Deutschen dreiviertel die haben ihr Geld
halt auf Sparbüchern
Tagesgeldkonten und Lebensversicherung
ja und das wird massiv entwertet das
heißt da geht die gesamte Altersvorsorge
kaputt und das ist ja noch meine andere
Dimension ob ich sage ich muss jetzt mal
ein Winter irgendwo höhere Heizkosten
oder sowas auch schlimmes oder dann die
Frage meine ganze Altersvorsorge war
vielleicht für die Katz wenn wir noch
ein paar Jahre die Inflation haben also
Nummer und das hatten wir auch noch
nicht also wir hatten mal vor 20 vor 40
Jahren war die Inflation genauso hoch
wie jetzt ja 1981 starten wir auch so 7
8 Prozent aber damals gab es elf Prozent
für eine Bundesanleihe heute ist ein
Prozent das ist doch der große
Unterschied deswegen das hatten wir noch
nie dass da auf dem Weg eine aktuelle
Leute stattfindet und die die
Altersvorsorge von der ganzen Generation
wenn das so weitergeht mit der Inflation
wird ein paar Jahre zerstört wird
letztlich in der Tat kann man auch in
dem Fall der Ampel man kann sie für
vieles verantwortlich machen aber ich
glaube für die aktuelle Inflation nicht
oder wenn überhaupt nicht so ganz
geringen Teilen aber ich glaube es zeigt
sich noch mal auch was für ein
historischer Fehler ist von Angela
Merkel gewesen ist bei der Neubesetzung
der Spitzenposition der Europäischen
Zentralbank nämlich dem
Präsidentenposten sich nicht gegen
Emanuel macron durchgesetzt zu haben
sondern da den Kürzeren gezogen zu haben
wir sind die größte Volkswirtschaft als
Deutschland in Europa es gibt eine
hervorragende wie ich finde Tradition
geldpolitische Tradition der Bundesbank
die extrem auf Stabilität gesetzt hat
und wenn man aber anschaut die 20 Jahre
Euro die wir jetzt haben dann war noch
nie ein Deutscher oder eine deutsche
Präsident dieser Europäischen
Zentralbank es war einmal Holländer der
hat das gut gemacht der musste aber dann
aus verschiedenen Gründen seine Amtszeit
zur Hälfte abtreten dann war es zweimal
ein franz schon einmal Italiener alles
Länder die aus der Erfahrung und aus der
Historie heraus eher nicht so für eine
starke und sehr strikte Geldpolitik
geworben haben oder das in ihrer
Tradition haben sondern eigentlich immer
mit Inflation gelebt haben das Recht
sich jetzt auf dramatische Weise und ich
kann nur appellieren ich glaube die
Ampel in ihrer jetzigen Zusammensetzung
wird es glaube ich immer auf sieben
Jahre gewählt die Chefin der
Europäischen Zentralbank wird es
möglicherweise nicht mehr erleben diese
Ampel zumindest nicht vielleicht gibt es
auch keine weitere was auch immer aber
die aktuelle Bundesregierung nicht aber
der Appell glaube ich kann nur sein für
die nächste Bundesregierung alles dafür
zu tun dass der nächste EZB-Chef oder
die nächste ezb-chefin auf jeden Fall
aus Deutschland kommt aus der Tradition
der Bundesbank nicht umsonst haben schon
drei top Geldpolitiker in der EZB ja
hingeschmissen drei deutsche weil sie es
nicht mehr ausgehalten haben
das ist Zukunftsmusik und wäre schön
wenn es so wird aber eine Frage habe ich
noch ganz konkret zu ihnen Robert Habeck
also der Wirtschaftsminister hat heute
auch davor gewarnt dass man den sozialen
Frieden zusammenhalten muss und den
Frieden ist die Politik sich dann
bewusst wie groß der soziale Sprengstoff
eigentlich auch gerade in diesem Land
ist wenn Menschen Angst haben ihr Gas
nicht mehr zahlen zu können ihre mieten
ist man sich da gewahr im Bundestag so
der Bundeskanzler der gesagt you never
walk alone also du bleibst nicht alleine
wir lassen dich nicht alleine wir
schaffen das da kriegt man aber als
Bürger immer fast Angst
also wir werden das hinbekommen
Angela Merkel erinnert
man kann sich darauf verlassen dass wir
das im Auge haben aber was wir auch
sagen sollten ehrlich ist dass wir nicht
wissen wie die Entwicklung der nächsten
sogar Jahre sein wird allerdings gibt es
eine positive Entwicklung die wir sehen
können glaube ich wir werden
möglicherweise in der Rezession kommen
zeitnah das heißt aber nicht
zwangsläufig dass der Arbeitsmarkt das
ist eine neue Situation in Deutschland
dass der Arbeitsmarkt schwer getroffen
sein wird schlichtweg weil wir ehrlich
gesagt ein Arbeitskräftemangel haben da
kommen wir vielleicht später noch mal
mit Handwerk
auszugleichen die Frage ist auch genau
wie die Inflation kompensiert wird über
Lohnsteigerungen aber was eher nicht zu
erwarten ist ist dass wir jetzt in der
Phase der Massenarbeitslosigkeit
zurückkehren die wir schon mal hatten
vor 20 Jahren selbst wenn wir jetzt bei
der Wachstumsrate ins Minus gehen glaube
ich können wir da zumindest den Leuten
Sicherheit in der Arbeit weitestgehend
versprechen und das ist ja schon mal was
ja du siehst es etwas düsterer wie die
Zukunft aussieht aber bzw wie die
Regierung mit uns Bürgern umgeht zum
einen würde ich mich erstmal dem
Anschließen was die der gerne Check
gerade gesagt hat dass die
wirtschaftliche Situation sicherlich
überhaupt nicht gut ist und die Frage ob
es Proteste gibt und der eine andere
sagt ja schon das werden Proteste sein
die vor allem Ostdeutschland stattfinden
gibt doch eine Innenministerin die den
die da protestieren werden gleich den
Stempel rechts und rechtsradikal
aufdrückt so weit würde ich überhaupt
nicht gehen aber was ich schon
feststelle ist oder was wir feststellen
müssen glaube ich dass wir
eine neue Krise haben wir ein erst
Corona jetzt haben wir die Energiekrise
wir haben eine neue Regierung ist die
groko jetzt die Ampel aber die
Verhaltensmuster seit Corona offenbar
doch die gleichen sind denn wir erinnern
uns alle an dass fast schon übergriffige
oder das übergriffige muss man sagen das
Staates Widerstand in der
corona-pandemie anfing bis ins kleinste
Detail das Leben der Bürger zu bestimmen
da durfte ab 22 Uhr nicht mehr
zusammengejoggt werden und alleine
durfte man nur ab zwischen Mitternacht
und 5 Uhr morgens gar nicht mehr joggen
gehen für ein paar Monate da wurde
festgelegt wie viele Kinder so
Kindergeburtstagen noch erscheinen
dürfen da gab es eine Grenze von 10 von
der maskenpflicht möchte ich gar nicht
sprechen also da wurde bis ins kleinste
Detail das Leben der Bürger geregelt und
was die Folge war das war natürlich
Proteste auf den Straßen und das sehen
wir jetzt wieder die Bundesregierung in
Form der Ampel hat heute auch zwei
Pakete sogar
verabschiedet zwei verordnungspakete
Gesetz Pakete das eine wieder zu Corona
das andere zum Thema Energiesparen wenn
man da genau reinschaut dann sieht man
auch wieder viele Dinge wo man sagen
muss hier wird der staatübergriffig und
macht Dinge die ihn nicht zustehen
beispielsweise Beleuchtung Beleuchtung
in Geschäften Nina Schinken hat das
gerade schon angesprochen von 22 Uhr bis
16 Uhr ist es ab September untersagt für
Geschäftsleute Leuchtwerbung zu schalten
das muss man sich mal vorstellen da darf
man keine Werbung mehr anmachen die
leuchtet um Energie zu sparen und ab
September ist beispielsweise auch
Geschäftsleuten und hier sitzt eine
Inhaberin eines Friseursalons mit am
Tisch ist es untersagt die Türen
dauerhaft offen zu lassen die müssen
also geschlossen sein als wenn jemand
der Kaufmann ist und vielleicht das
Geschäft sogar ein zweiter oder dritter
Generation betreibt nicht weiß wie man
Geld zusammenhält wie man spart also
Robert Habeck der noch nie in der freien
Wirtschaft gearbeitet hat der muss jetzt
kommen und Menschen die seit Jahren in
der freien Nacht arbeiten zu sagen wie
sie Energien sparen sollen das ist
übergriffig und den Vogel hat heute
Heine Karl Lauterbach abgeschossen
beim Thema
maskenpflicht auf die Frage warum
eigentlich in
regierungsfliegern Politiker ohne Maske
fliegen dürfen ganz normale Bürger das
muss ich aber sagen genau so weil ich
mal reinhören ganz normale Bürger aber
auf dem Linien oder ferienflug mit Maske
fliegen müssen und diese maskenpflicht
ist heute noch mal Verschärfung darauf
auf diese Frage warum das ist hat Karl
Lauterbach geantwortet
und das ist das sozusagen das
rechtfertigt ist
eigentlich nicht naja es ist eben so es
gibt eigene Regeln für die Luftwaffe und
für die Flugbereitschaft und die sind
hier zur zum Einsatz gekommen und über
diese Regeln hinaus sind dann diejenigen
die mitgereist sind noch getestet worden
es ist ebenso sagt Karl Lauterbach es
ist ebenso meine Damen und Herren liebe
Zuschauer das hat spaltungspotenzial
absolut also diese Übergriffigkeit diese
Hochnäsigkeit diese Doppelmoral und
diese Arroganz von Karl Lauterbach in
diesem Fall die sorgt dafür dass das
Land gespalten wird und genau diese auch
Maßnahmen sind es dass die Menschen auf
die Straße gehen werden die Ampel tut
also das Gegenteil von dem was sie
eigentlich will sie führt nicht zusammen
sondern sie spaltet Herren
seine harsche Kritik und der Ampel also
was Corona angeht nehmen wir jetzt im
Wesentlichen ja Maßnahmen zurück wir
werden im parlamentarischen Verfahren
auch noch mal genau hinschauen ich
zumindest persönlich dass die Kinder
wirklich vollständig ausgenommen werden
dass man nicht einfach sagen kann ihr
müsst jetzt Maske aufsetzen weil wir
Lust zu haben ab der fünften Klasse
dann wirklich ein Grund geben dass das
Gesundheitssystem wirklich nachweisbar
überlastet ist vor Ort und nicht dass
man dann sagt oh jetzt ist Oktober ist
kalt die Maske muss auf dem würde ich
auf jeden Fall widersprechen und
natürlich
bacho was empfinden Sie da
auch echt nur als Politik nur in dem
Fall würde ich ihn sogar ausnahmsweise
verteidigen ich bin ja jetzt nicht ein
großer Freund gewesen seiner
Kommunikation weil da einfach die
Regelung beschrieben hat die ist ja so
aber ob die so richtig ist das ist ja
und ob die fair und gerecht ist im
Verständnis der Bürger da würde ich
sagen nein natürlich ist das ein Bild
was nicht gut ist wenn auf der einen
Seite alle gewisse Pflichten haben auf
der anderen dann und da kommt ja dann
auch schnell die Idee die da oben die
nehmen sich die eigenen Regeln das ist
kein Bild das gut ist und das muss man
dann einfach auch so sagen dass das
nicht gut ist bin ich einmal einhaken
darf beim Thema maskenpflicht in Schulen
das was die Ampel auch dort beschlossen
hat ist ja keine Pflicht sondern ist ja
eine Empfehlung und man kann dann wenn
die Lehrer der Meinung sind hier droht
eine Schulschließung zu einer
maskenpflicht kommen
aus eigener Erfahrung kann ich Ihnen
sagen und ich habe eine sehr hohe und
gute Meinung von von Lehrern weil die
sehr engagiert sind in der Regel an den
Schulen herrscht eine Angst vor Corona
das auch jetzt bereits so etwas wie eine
maskenpflicht gibt zumindest an Berliner
Schulen das geht dann soweit dass
Schüler im Unterricht die Fälle gibt es
die keine Maske tragen von einem Lehrer
der Maske trägt in die letzte Reihe
gesetzt während der herrscht echte
Masken Diskriminierung und deswegen
glaube ich dass es dass wir spätestens
zum ersten Oktober
eine Welle von
maskenpflichten an den Schulen sehen
werden wenn ich sogar schon vorher weil
einfach in den Schulen ein Fehler
herrscht als ob wir im Februar 2020
werden und nicht im Herbst oder
Spätsommer des Jahres 2022 und die
meisten drei oder vierfach geimpft sind
ja ich habe selber drei Kinder an
diversen Schulen unterschiedlichster Art
und
diese Kultur der Angst die hat
geherrscht und ich hoffe sie wird jetzt
ein Stück weit aufgebrochen aus ihren
Erfahrungen herrscht sie immer noch also
kommen auch nach wie vor so viele
Zuschauer es gibt natürlich jetzt auch
ein Gewöhnungseffekt weil viele Menschen
die zum Beispiel Angst hatten dass sich
Kinder infizieren gemerkt haben dass
Gott sei Dank bei den allermeisten
Kindern das keine schweren Verläufe gibt
und übrigens jetzt auch mit der Omegon
Variante auch bei älteren wenn sie dann
geimpft sind vor allem das hilft
natürlich dann die schweren Verläufe
ausbleiben schön ist es nicht ich hatte
auch Corona mich hat es nicht ganz so
hart erwischt meine Frau ein bisschen
stärker andere haben es noch stärker
gehabt aber man gewöhnt sich doch an den
Zustand man muss es wirklich noch mal
sagen weil mich das auch maßlos ärgert
ich habe zwar keine Kinder aber es
ärgert mich trotzdem maßlos als Bürgerin
muss denn die Ampel und dirigiert nun
mal jetzt nicht endlich was dagegen tun
gegen diese Masken Diskriminierung bei
Kindern was das Beispiel was Jan Schäfer
jetzt erzählt hat wir kriegen jeden Tag
Zuschauer Post darüber dass Eltern und
Schreiben Kinder müssen im Bus weil der
Busfahrer ist möchte kinder müssen in
der Schule die mussten dann auch testen
auf dem Flur damit schön jeder sieht wer
auch nicht geimpft ist und so weiter es
passiert so viel es gab Denkzettel wenn
ihr meine Maske nicht getragen hat muss
der ausfüllen warum nicht muss die Ampel
da nicht mal ganz entschieden vielleicht
sogar meine Pressekonferenz geben an die
Lehrer appellieren man kann doch nicht
immer sagen es sollte nicht so sein aber
die Kinder trifft immer noch also
erstens glaube ich sind es nicht die
Lehrer sondern Teile der
verbandsvertreter:innen die dort
unterwegs sind und sehr scharf sind wenn
ich nur einen Meidinger denke der
übrigens mein Sozialkunde Lehrer aus der
Schule in Niederbayern war also wir
kennen uns persönlich aber sind nichts
einer Meinung in dieser Frage wie man
Angst kommen
vor einigen Wochen auf einem privaten
fest und
wir haben dann aber nicht darüber
gesprochen
der hat ja öffentlich auch schon
manchmal gehört dass ich ihn
widersprochen habe aber ich will schon
sagen es herrschte eine
angstkommunikation auch in den Schulen
die viele Menschen traumatisiert hat und
das ist auch ein Versagen von
politikkommunikation aber auch von
Medienkommunikation gewesen weil man
Risikoeinschätzung irgendwann ja auch
mal einordnen muss und nicht der Faktor
1000 dann in den Köpfen höher ist als er
real ist und ich bin der Meinung das hat
vielen geschadet und jetzt wissen wir
doch dass wir doch gut und sicher mit
den Kindern durch den Winter kommen es
wird Fälle geben es wird Infektionen
geben meine Kinder waren schon zweimal
durch ist alles nicht schön aber es ist
ja auch keine Alternative da also wir
wollen ein normales Leben Wirklichkeit
des Staates auch war also wenn man jetzt
Jens Schäfer zugehört hat und ich stimme
da auch zu nehmen sie nicht wahr das
Übergriffigkeit herrschen dass sich der
Staat zu sehr in private Entscheidung
eingemischt hat es gibt sicherlich Teile
der politischen Klasse nicht nur der
britischen Klasse auch Teile der Medien
Dritter Teile der Verbandsvertreter die
ich würde mal sagen im ersten Jahr
gestehe ich allen alles zu da hatte ich
würde ich auch sagen weil ich wieder
Lockdown und so weiter und auch wenn
zweiten aber irgendwann muss man ja mal
in Richtung
Eigenverantwortung und sagen dreimal
impfen war möglich wir mal von mir aus
auch wenn ihr wollt Maske tragen könnte
also irgendwann muss man ja mal auch das
Politik sagen als Gesellschaft sagen wir
haben jetzt alles getan ihr habt alle
Instrumente da und wir können jetzt
nicht über die Köpfe von vielen die auch
damit sehr großes Befremden haben
weiterentscheiden dass wir tief
Mikromanagement machen eingreifen und da
sind wir noch nicht ganz raus in
Deutschland also sie zerstören gerade im
positiven Sinn mein Bild von den Grünen
ich darf mal ganz ehrlich sagen wie das
ist die passen da nicht so richtig rein
gebe ich zu ich glaube manche Grüne
haben einfach eine gewisse Freude dran
das Leben von Menschen so mit dem
Management ob das jetzt Corona ist oder
ob das jetzt die Gelegenheit ist
Waschlappen anstatt Duschen das ist ja
so ähnlich wie bei manchen Religionen ja
die auch so den Menschen gern mit Heil
vorschreiben was ich jeden Tag zu tun
und zu lassen haben und das ist bei den
Grünen da gibt es auch manche bei den
Sozialdemokraten meine linken bei
anderen auch ja wird so ein bisschen das
Problem glaube ich der Staat soll sich
mal darauf konzentrieren was seine
eigentliche Aufgabe ist neu oft versagt
ja wir haben eine Bundeswehr die in
Schrotthaufen ist ja wir haben die
Digitalisierung vollkommen verschlafen
ja da gibt es noch viele Baustellen die
wir alle aufzählen könnten statt immer
in das Alltagsleben der Menschen ständig
und ich glaube einfach wirklich
zerstören sie gerne meine Meinung aber
können sie auch vielleicht nicht so
offen sagen ich glaube manche von ihren
grünen Parteifreunden die haben schon
diebische Freude den es macht richtig
Spaß das kann man den Leuten wieder
irgendwie was vorschreiben so und das
ist also
jetzt einfach auch mal so ganz pauschal
weil es auf ihr Parteiprogramm einzieht
ja dass man den Reichen jetzt den
reichen auch das ganz bewusst gesagt
jetzt den Pool ausstellt das muss man
sich mal überlegen was spart das
eigentlich genau an Gast wenn Robert
Habeck sagt die zwei Prozent die wir
dann zu sich an Gast Strömung brauchen
weil wir die Kernkraftwerke abschalten
das ist nicht das Problem ja wie viel
Gas sparen wir denn eigentlich weil wir
da irgendwie 1000 Pools kalt stellen das
ist in 0,000 Bereich
aber das zählt genau darauf ein den
Menschen zu sagen was sie zu tun haben
was sie nicht zu tun haben die groß ist
das Stichwort also am besten auch gar
nicht mehr Auto fahren nur noch
irgendwie im im kollektivistischen
Transportmittel Bahn unterwegs sein das
ist genau das die Heizung runter Licht
aus Frühling aus irgendwann wird es dazu
kommen dass auch ein Privatwohnung muss
Kerze an warum machen Sie es mit weil
sie keine Alternative zurzeit haben wenn
die FDP aussteigt verlieren ein Drittel
der Abgeordneten ihren Sitz falls es neu
war und wenn die SPD aussteigt stellt
die SPD im Bundeskanzler nicht mehr denn
dann könnten beispielsweise grüne und
auch die FDP ist keine Neuwahlen mit
einem Kanzler in der März beispielsweise
dann reagieren also die Grünen sind
eigentlich in der besten Position muss
man ganz klar sagen deswegen ist das
zurzeit der starke Machtfaktor in der
Ampel schwach sind SPD und FDP aber SPD
müsst ihr eigentlich gar nicht schwach
sein SPD hat ja sogar den Kanzler
gestellt also geht es in der Politik
eigentlich nur darum seinen Sitz zu
behalten wenn man ihn einmal hat egal
was jetzt für eine also FDP hat mal
gesagt lieber nicht regieren als falsch
regieren dementsprechend fragt man sich
aktuell schon mal wie lange die FDP das
jetzt mitgeht oder wann sie findet dass
es falsch regieren ist oder aber die
Option aus einer Koalition auszusteigen
und die FDP war schon mal ein extrem
schwierigen Lage zwischen 2009 und 2013
und ist nicht ausgestiegen die Partei
jetzt fast zerrissen in der Frage muss
man Griechenland unterstützen muss
Griechenland im Euro bleiben oder eben
nicht gab ein Partei Wechsel an der
Spitze also da war richtig was los und
danach ist sie aus dem Parlament
geflogen diese Lehre war für die FDP
oder diese Erfahrung extrem heilsam und
es gibt immer holen und tief muss man
auch sagen wer weiß wie es im halben
Jahr ist vielleicht sind die Grünen ein
bisschen schwächer wieder die FDP ein
bisschen stärker die SPD
aber es macht aus politischer Sicht
nicht aus Sicht des Wähler sage ich gar
nicht aber aus politischer Sicht aus
Sicht derjenigen die jetzt für die FDP
beispielsweise im Bundestag sitzen und
da ein Mandat haben macht es eigentlich
wenig Sinn rauszugehen weil es
einerseits auch bei einigen
Glaubwürdigkeit kostet bei anderen
vielleicht nicht aber falls es zu
Neuwahlen kommen sollte und das wäre
sicherlich etwas was die Grünen dann
anstreben würden die Union mit
Sicherheit auch dann müsste eine FDP die
jetzt bei 7% Umfang steht oder viele der
Abgeordneten damit rechnen dass sie
nicht mehr im Bundestag kommen und bei
der SPD wer es genauso das
Aussagen ab und Anna muss ich einmal
fragen ich sehe sie manchmal so ein
bisschen schmunzeln um ihre Lippen wobei
Schmunzeln sie so genau und haben Sie
denn Lust am verbieten die Grünen was
wir hier sehr wem denn vorwerfen Robert
Habeck würde ich sagen ist ein sehr
liberaler Politiker also auch als
Wirtschaftspolitiker tut er ja schon das
was jetzt notwendig ist und beschafft
zum Beispiel das Gas von Kanada
vielleicht auch noch Katar weiß ich
nicht auf jeden Fall ist er auf der Welt
unterwegs
Sozialpolitiker der Vorschuss hat Sie
gereizt das muss ich einfach mal sagen
ein liberaler Politiker der vorschreibt
wann ein Unternehmer Leuchtwerbung
schalten darf der vorschreibt dass ein
Unternehmer die Türen zu seinem Geschäft
nicht aufhaben darf jetzt unter uns
Entschuldigung ist ja nicht erst April
liberal und Staatssozialismus das passt
nicht wir müssen halt die 20 Prozent das
ist ja manchmal Pragmatismus wir
brauchen halt eine Einsparung und dann
müssen wir auch ein paar Vorgaben machen
und es ist ja jetzt nicht das Schlimmste
für die Wirtschaft dass die nachts dann
die Beleuchtung aussah das ist der
Kollektivismus den die Gründer sie sind
dann bis zur Aufgabe würde mich selber
zum Beispiel auch als liberal und Grünen
bezeichnet
Unternehmer vorschreiben so die
Leuchtreklame oben der Firmenname bleibt
jetzt aus muss ich ja nur machen weil
wir die 20 Prozent ein schalten
wir überhaupt eine weiß ich nicht also
dann gehe ich davon aus dass wir die
Ausscheiden
gehe habe ich noch eine Frage an die
Koalition ist stabil wir werden keine
Neuwahlen und so weiter deswegen habe
Kanzler Habeck und Vizekanzler Merz also
ist ja noch lange hin aber das die
Grünen beim letzten Mal schon angestrebt
haben die Kanzlerschaft das wird sich
beim nächsten Mal nicht ändern so wird
das sein wer dann der Kandidat sein wird
werden wir sehen damit geben wir in eine
ganz kurze Unterbrechung stellen uns
schon mal vor wie das da wohl bei der
nächsten Wahl sein wird und sind gleich
wieder zurück
[Musik]
ernst nehmen als sogenannten Experten
herzlich willkommen meine Damen und
Herren bei viertel nach fünf Köpfen fünf
Meinungen von jeder von uns hat ein
Thema mitgebracht dass sie bewegt ärgert
freut oder schockiert
so nicht Privatchat Uschi Jürgen
aber niemand von den politischen
Parteien traut sich zu sagen ja das
wollen wir einfach nur Freiheit wir sind
grün-roten stehen da und führen
hochtrabende Debatten über die Rettung
des Weltklimas und um die Füße rum wo
sollen die Ratten das Thema ist viel zu
wichtig uns nur der AFD zu überlassen
lass den Leuten noch mal den Spaß wir
sehen da etwas was eigentlich fatal ist
in der Politik bei den Journalisten
deren Job ist es doch gerade abweichende
Meinungen zu finden und sie sollen den
doch auch richtig doof finden
zu Manko vielleicht einmal kurz an das
Auto
das sind irgendwelche anorakträger aus
Buxtehude die das Gucken ich habe mein
Beifall in meine lache immer bekommen
wer kümmert sich darum niemand bitte
ja man muss da ganz klar jetzt mal auch
darüber sprechen dass es einfach nicht
fährt und nicht richtig Aufgabe von
Journalismus einfach die die
Verlautbarung der Politik zu
hinterfragen
[Musik]
wir sind zurück verlieren keine Zeit und
gehen ganz geschwind zur These von
grünen Politiker und
Bundestagsabgeordneten
ja liebe Zuseherin das Thema was mir
besonders am Herzen liegt sind die
kleinen Kulturbetriebe Theater Kinos die
sind ja alle wieder offen Gott sei Dank
und haben momentan auch keine
Restriktion aber trotzdem kommen zu
wenig Leute zu wenig Leute gehen ins
Theater es gibt hier zum Beispiel ein
Berliner Wedding das Primetime tolles
kieztheater bei mir in München das
Backstage einen tollen Club aber die
Leute gehen noch nicht hin manche haben
Angst verstehe ich aber ich möchte dich
einfach mal appellieren auch an sie
nutzen sie wieder die kulturellen
Gelegenheiten auch in ländlichen
Regionen die es so viel gibt weil das
sind so viele Leute mit Herzblut
unterwegs die was leisten die brauchen
jetzt auch wieder Publikum und ich habe
auch eine Bitte an meine eigene
Bundesregierung als Parlament bitte
schafft für diesen Winter keine Regeln
die die Geschäftsmodelle dieser
Unternehmen wieder so einschränken dass
nichts geht das geht übrigens auch für
Messen für Veranstaltungswirtschaft also
gibt den kleinen wieder eine Chance weil
die haben tolles angeboten wir müssen
das den wieder helfen dass das klappt
mit dem
8:15 Uhr zu Gast aber als ich eben
gerade diesen diesen diese Bilder
gesehen habe habe ich mich erinnert wie
viele künst eigentlich auch ein
Aufschrei gemacht haben während der
ganzen Maßnahmen und die wurden ja
teilweise als zum Beispiel bei Jan Josef
Liefers wurde sogar gefordert dass er
kein Tatort Kommissar mehr ist und das
sogar von einem öffentlich-rechtlichen
Journalisten wie schlimm glauben Sie
denn rückblickend war es dass die
Künstler nicht mehr gehört wurden dass
die Regierung nicht sich mehr mit den
Künstlern zusammengesetzt hat also bei
den Künstlern gab es auch
unterschiedliche Meinungen wie man mit
der Pandemie umzugehen hat aber
insgesamt war das Meinungsklima in
Deutschland in der Pandemie ich sage es
mal ganz deutlich unterirdisch in vielen
Bereichen Menschen die einzelnen
Maßnahmen kritisiert haben und ich rede
jetzt nicht von Leuten die sagen es gibt
kein Corona oder es gibt einen Impfstoff
der ist doof oder so
also einzelne Maßnahmen die wurden dann
auch gleich in die querdecker-ecke
gesteckt und so und das war nicht in
Ordnung
wieder aufzumachen noch 150 Tagen
Netzwerken ist das ja ganz normal wobei
mich das mittlerweile überhaupt nicht
beeindruckt mehr aber es ist trotzdem
hart gewesen dass Menschen wie gesagt
haben wir wollen wieder kulturelles
Leben haben gerne auch indem wir eigene
Maßnahmen
Hygienemaßnahmen machen ob die jetzt gut
sind oder nicht und die haben das
versucht und wurden dann immer sehr
schnell in der Ecke gestellt das war
nicht gut und aktuell sind ja immer noch
ganz viel Konzerte wo wenig Tickets
verkauft werden deswegen haben ihre
teesorteamt gibt es denn irgendein
Lösungsvorschlag den sie haben außerhalb
dieses Appells das eine ist schon dass
wir jetzt keine neuen
kapazitätsobergrenzen für den Winter
schaffen weil wenn Sie jetzt das
Einkaufszentrum offen halten und laufen
15.000 Leute durch am Tag und auf der
anderen Seite muss dann die Messe planen
und weiß nicht was sie planen muss dann
macht die keine Messe ja und so ist es
eben bei den Theatern auch wenn die
heute schon wissen ab Oktober gibt es
sozusagen auf jeden Fall maskenpflicht
im Theater und Abstand dann ist
sozusagen das Geschäft am Ende ja und da
müssen wir auf Eigenverantwortung setzen
ich habe da überhaupt kein Problem wenn
Leute sagen sie wollen sich schützen mit
einer Maske finde ich super aber wenn
sie es nicht wollen dann ist es auch
super und zu dem Zustand müssen wir
jetzt hinkommen ja wie sieht das
politisch aus wie wahrscheinlich ist es
das doch Maske beispielsweise eine Oper
oder auch die oberbegrenzung wenn du
Karl Lauterbach wie heute in der
Pressekonferenz dazu gehört hast also es
halte ich für durchaus realistisch ob
ich das gut finde ist in einer Frage und
ich glaube der Appell den sie da gemacht
haben der ist dringend den müssten sie
aber wahrscheinlich vielleicht auch in
einem Brandbrief oder einem Brand Aufruf
über Social Media wie auch immer gerne
auch nach zwei Karl Lauterbach ja auch
nachts wach ist wie wir alle wissen und
auch Twitter liest aber direkt glaube
ich an den Bundesgesundheitsminister
errichten denn der hat natürlich heute
auch in seiner Pressekonferenz einmal
mehr vor einem ganz ganz schlimmen
Herbst gewahrt also der hat einen ein
Bild gezeichnet dass er ja schon seit
Wochen also seit Monaten muss man fast
sagen zeichnet und hat eigentlich
neue Untergangsszenarien skizziert
interessant sie haben das ja auch vor
Beginn der Sendung kurz gesagt wenn man
den Liberalen Marco Buschmann daneben
gehabt gesehen hat als Justizminister
dachte man die Reden über zwei
verschiedene Dinge weil der versucht als
runterzudecken aber Lauterbach hat
selbst gesagt wir haben die Maßnahmen
noch mal verschärft und das führt
natürlich zu einem Klima das was sie
auch gerade Ansprachen das
wahrscheinlich viele Menschen wieder
sagen Gottes Willen um Gottes Willen
nicht nur in Schulen sondern auch für
Menschen die gerne in Kulturbetriebe
gehen oder auf Messen auf in Theater in
Kinos können wir uns das eigentlich noch
zumuten ist das nicht alles wieder viel
zu gefährlich deswegen meine mein Rat
vielleicht wenn ich das überhaupt sagen
darf an sie
nachts jetzt heute Nacht alles klar
die müssen das ihm glaube ich direkt
einmal gucken aber antwortet aber wie
ist denn das Denning von Karl Lauterbach
zum Beispiel ihrer Partei ist es noch
ein sicherer Gesundheitsminister der
sicher sitzt oder wird es schon immer
lauter dass man sagt also langsam kann
man es nicht mehr tragen nee der hat ja
auch viele Fans also ist ja auch okay
hat ja auch vieles durchaus auch
geleistet indem er frühzeitig gewarnt
hat die Frage ist ob man irgendwann
wieder rauskommt aus dem Modus also
insofern
nee ich bin nicht so ein Fan seiner
Kommunikation respektiere dass er mit
einem guten ansehen unterwegs ist und
dass er auch viel weiß aber was mir
nicht gefällt ist dass man Seite
systematisch auch ein Stück weit
verängstigt und zwar mit so Sachen dass
man sagt da kommt jetzt der Killer Virus
dann kommt ja nicht und jetzt kommt dann
wieder immer das Schlimmste und wenn
immer das Schlimmste kommt dann tut das
der Seele weh den Menschen und das ist
auch gefährlich also die psychische
Seite der Pandemie die ist
vernachlässigt die psychische also zum
Beispiel Karl Lauterbach hat ja heute
auch die Impfstoffe die dann auch vor
Infektionen schützen werden Stör macht
sich lustig darüber wenn man das so
formulieren kann ist es nicht auch
langsam aus medizinischer Sicht so sie
sind jetzt kein Arzt was man sich schon
als Bürger sind ja auch Bürgermeister
fragt ob das alles noch so viel Sinn
macht
ich bin immer bei der Ständigen
Impfkommission die wurde ja auch stark
angegriffen ich fand das immer gut dass
sie sich auch die Zeit genommen haben
diese gebraucht haben selbst wenn der
Druck hoch war und die haben die
Empfehlungen zu geben und danach impfe
ich mich deswegen bin ich jetzt dreimal
geimpft ich bin nicht 60 Jahre alt wenn
ich 60 wäre würde ich mich aus vierte
Mal impfen
ich würde zum Beispiel auch sagen dass
die Kultureinrichtungen auch eine
Relevanz dahingehend haben dass die
Menschen das auch einfach für Ihre
mentale Gesundheit brauchen und auch
sich mal wieder so ein bisschen zu
trauen in Interaktion zu begeben in den
Austausch zu gehen ich glaube
da merkt man halt andere Folgen der
Pandemie jetzt nicht im gesundheitlichen
sondern eben dass das auch was mit
unseren miteinander macht und ich habe
zum Beispiel auch regelmäßig Austausch
mit meinen Kundinnen und Kunden und man
merkt schon dass das bei allen Spuren
hinterlassen hat und da würde ich ich
hatte auch mal Zeit lang im
Kulturbetrieb gearbeitet und würde auch
sagen dass das wichtig ist für unser
gesellschaftliches Miteinander und
deswegen denke ich jetzt das schon wenn
wir konkret zu Ihnen kommen sie haben
einen Friseursalon sie sind
friseurhandwerksmeisterin die Frage ist
jetzt natürlich die ich mir stelle wie
ging es ihnen psychisch während der
lockdowns und wenn sie jetzt daran
denken dass gleich wieder schließen
müssen also da ist man natürlich schon
besorgt also ich bin in der vollen
Selbstständigkeit das heißt ich lebe
ausschließlich davon ich muss sagen
es ist halt so dass ich natürlich mit
Vorsicht an das Thema rangehe auf der
anderen Seite
jeder ist irgendwie ja so ein bisschen
zwiegespalten die einen die wollen
irgendwie wieder so ein bisschen die
Freiheit so zurück ja und die anderen
sind so ein bisschen vorsichtig und
ja also ich versuche die maskenpflicht
so gut es geht beizubehalten um Halt zu
schützen und das auch meine Kunden sich
geschützt fühlen ich mache mir aber
schon auch ein bisschen Sorge auch
natürlich aus finanzieller Sicht ob das
am Ende dann Einschränkungen hat dass
wir nicht schließen muss das aber sie
lieben das Handwerk trotzdem warum
finden Sie das Handwerk vor Studium sein
sollte also ich kann sagen dass das
Handwerk sehr viele Möglichkeiten bietet
und dass man heutzutage wirklich viele
Zukunftsperspektiven mit dem Handwerk
hat und dass es nicht zwangsläufig zum
Beispiel nach dem Abitur ein Studium
sein muss sondern dass man sich da sehr
gut selbst verwirklichen kann und eine
eigene Handschrift kriegen kann
und was macht das Handwerk so besonders
warum erfreuen sie sich so sehr an ihrem
Handwerks große Sandra das ist auch gut
man muss nicht studieren man kann auch
das Handwerk machen und lieben aber was
ist so besonders daran wenn man ein
Handwerksmeister ist ich habe das Gefühl
dass ich großen Einfluss mit meiner
Arbeit habe also dass zum Beispiel ich
wenn ich eine Braut frisiere dass ich
dann langfristig auf den Bildern zu
sehen bin mit meiner Tätigkeit und dass
ich auch finde dass das eine eigene
Handschrift hat also ich kann in
direktes Feedback meiner Arbeit bekommen
ich sehe was ich gemacht habe und ja
viele Menschen profitieren auch davon
finden Sie das wird in der Politik gut
rübergebracht also dass die Politik in
Deutschland das Handwerk auch genug
fördert und schätzt und das da genug für
getan wird vor allem in der
Bildungspolitik natürlich also ich muss
jetzt aus eigener Erfahrung sagen ich
hatte jetzt zum Beispiel als ich meinen
Meister gemacht habe schon Unterstützung
erhalten also es gab aufstiegs-bafög
oder es gab viele Zuschüsse ja das gibt
es schon aber nichtsdestotrotz würde ich
behaupten dass so eine grundsätzliche
Kommunikation irgendwie fehlt also ich
das Gefühl habe zum Beispiel auch zum
Thema
Nachwuchs finden
wo holt man die Jugend von heute ab und
ist man nicht da vielleicht noch so ein
bisschen in so alten Strukturen gefangen
und es vielleicht auch der Aufbau der
Ausbildung manchmal auch noch so ein
bisschen ja veraltet und dass ich dann
manchmal denke ja gerne ich habe eine
ganz spannende Zahl für heute
recherchiert ja ich habe mich natürlich
auch an die Zahlen gesetzt und das
Handwerk ist im aktuellen Bundestag
schwächer repräsentiert als zuvor nur
noch 4,4 Prozent der Abgeordneten haben
handwerksbezug kann man da überhaupt
genug auf diese Bereiche eingehen
anstatt immer jünger und weiblicher
vielleicht auch mal mehr Handwerker im
Bundestag ja oder weibliches Handwerk
das wäre Herausforder auch möglich meine
Tochter nachzubringen damit sie nicht
Politiker werden muss und mal ein
bisschen Spaß zu machen aber
es ist schon also dem Handwerk insgesamt
geht es ja schon gut auch in Deutschland
das muss mir auch mal festhalten ich
glaube es gibt über 5 Millionen
Kleinstbetriebe in diesem Bereich ja und
die Aufträge sind da ist natürlich
unterschiedlich ob jetzt ein
Friseursalon habt oder zu sagen
Dachdecker bin oder erneuerbare Energien
gerade mache also wir haben eher gerade
das Problem dass wir die Fachkräfte
nicht kriegen ja nicht dass wir die
Betriebe nicht haben also die Nachfrage
auch in der Krise wird das sich nicht
substanziell ändern die ist da und was
im Bundestag angeht dass der manchmal
noch ein bisschen mehr Quereinsteiger
gebrauchen könnte ist so das gilt
allerdings für andere Branchen auch das
Auswahl des ganzen immer nicht alles nur
zählt was man dann vorher gemacht hat
ist halt auch die Wahrheit ja welchen
Handwerksberuf raten sie ihrer Tochter
aktuell
also die ist in zwei Jahren
wahrscheinlich so weit dass sie dann
Richtung vielleicht macht er noch was
anderes mal gucken ich kann sie ja ich
will sie jetzt auch nicht
TV sozusagen beraten aber ich glaube es
wäre gut zu schauen also gerade für
junge Mädchen mal zu gucken technische
Berufe Handwerksberufe bieten
unglaubliches Potenzial dann später auch
selbstständig zu sein und dieses
klassische Schema sozusagen der
Frauenberuf der Männerberuf das muss man
auflösen mich frage auch oft junge Leute
was soll ich denn jetzt studieren ja und
ich sag mal bevor du dir überlegst was
du studierst verleg Mal überhaupt
optisch studieren sollst ja weil ich
behaupte mal wer heute eine Ausbildung
macht was was ich als Fliesenleger als
Klempner als Heizungsinstallateur und
hat noch ein bisschen unternehmerisches
Talent dazu ja der wird wesentlich mehr
verdienen als die meisten Studenten und
der ist auch weltweit einsetzbar mit dem
jüngerstudium da bin ich weltweit nicht
der einsetzbar und da haben wir auch
viel zu viele von euch sprechen
kaputt das ist ein den ich auf jeden
Fall von den Handwerkern weiß die ich
kenne mit 60 leidet der Körper schon
spätestens und viele können dann auch
gar nicht mehr die zum Beispiel
Fliesenleger Maurer ist ein sehr harte
Berufe muss da vielleicht die Politik
stärker darauf eingehen dass natürlich
die körperlichen Anforderungen ganz
anders sind als wenn man jetzt Jurist im
Büro ist also ich habe es hat eher was
mit dem Ansehen und mit dem Respekt vor
den Berufen zu tun ich glaube eher der
Fehler ist dass viele denken also wenn
ich ein studiert habe ja dann ist es
weniger wert als wenn jemand Handwerker
ist das Problem bis 70 arbeiten in einem
Handwerksberufe mit 16-Jährigen und das
Fliesenleger oder Maurer ist oder zum
Beispiel auch Dreher ist mein Vater zum
Beispiel fallen weg mechanikermeister
deswegen kenne ich mich da ganz gut aus
würde ich sagen ist utopisch bis 70
dementsprechend hat das vielleicht auch
was damit zu tun außerhalb des Respekts
mag auch sein ob das jetzt primär die
Überlegung ist wenn einer 20 ist oder
sagt ich möchte nicht bis 70 arbeiten
oder ob dann nicht andere Sachen
Vordergrund stehen also ich sage ja auch
nicht dass jeder jetzt das machen muss
ich sage nochmal bevor du dir überlegst
was du studierst überlege über einmal ob
das nicht eine Alternative ist dass du
so eine Ausbildung machst mehr Geld
wirst du damit auf jeden Fall also oder
in vielen Fällen verdienen und halt wie
gesagt die internationale Flexibilität
viele sie möchten auch vielleicht mal
irgendwo im Ausland arbeiten und das da
bist Du wunderbar genommen als Deutscher
Heizungstechniker der Fliesenleger aber
garantiert nicht als deutsche Jurist
oder BWL also der wird nicht gebraucht
im Ausland wie siehst du das du hast
auch kinderhandwerk oder Studium oder
frei entscheidungswahl freie
entscheidungswahl ganz klar ich glaube
das ist hier auch nicht strittig dass
man seinen Kindern das eigentlich
wünscht dass sie sich so verwirklichen
um den Weg gehen der für Sie am besten
ist und ich sie das genau wie hier am
Tisch in dem Fall sind wir uns
wahrscheinlich alle einig ähm es muss
etwas sein was Hand und Fuß hat und nach
einem Abitur muss überhaupt nicht
zwangsläufig das Studium kommen da ist
glaube ich in den vergangenen 20 30 40
Jahren auch immer ein Fehler gemacht von
in dem Fall auch wieder von politischer
Seite zu sagen wir müssen eigentlich
alle an diese Universitäten kriegen gab
aber die Debatten darüber dass die dass
die Akademiker Quote auch in Deutschland
viel zu niedrig ist völliger Quatsch
jetzt sehen wir nämlich das Problem das
ist ganz ganz viele Handwerksbetriebe
gibt und sie haben das ja auch gesagt
beispielsweise auch beim Thema Ausbau
der Erneuerbaren da fehlt und fehlt und
fehlt es an Fachkräften also
anhandwerkern deswegen jeder soll auf
seine Fassung glücklich werden ob es ein
Studium ist ob es ein Handwerk Handwerk
eine Handwerkslehre ist oder ein
Handwerksmeister alles wunderbar das ist
ein schönes Schlusswort wir sind schon
am Ende der Sendung aber sie sind
übrigens perfekte Beispiel dafür er
studiert dann im Handwerksberuf
glücklich geworden und dementsprechend
ist heute der Schlusswort das tun was
ein glücklich macht ob es das Studium
oder die Ausbildung ist oder ja ein
Handwerksberuf schönen Abend noch und
wir sehen uns morgen abend wieder
tschüss
[Musik]